[Musique]
vous devez prouver que vous cherchez du
travail
j'ai pas mal cherché premier il vous
faut trois signatures demain au plus
tard vous vous expliquerez de vent chaud
quand avez vous travaillé dur pour
résoudre un problème ce matin pour me
lever
nous allons vous trouvez quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui vous plaira peu mes bras
et mes gens se substituer aux autres
j'adore ce que je trouve oui alors toit
terrasse vous devez attendre notre tour
voilà que c'est pas un braquage mais
vous pouvez signer la merci maman je
fais pour signer je sais pas moi
lentement
quoi vous ma marche pas non en effet ça
vous empêche pas de l'ouvrir je ne suis
pas le seul jeu requiert une assistance
ap combien je m'excuse mais désolée
autant pas vous n'avez pas les
qualifications requises pour cet emploi
la stature la ceinture vous avez déjà
changé un cathéter non il faut pincer
l'embout
série je ne sens rien du tout ben moi
chiante où vous voulez nourrir votre âme
écoutez la reine de la soul tech c'est
que bâle iii tout mais c'est bluffant
j'ai la même voie qu'elle ouais j'en
suis sidéré c'est aussi riche que djezzy
non plus riches
laquelle votre voiture seul sur votre
droite ne sont pas adaptés saké coule
[Musique]
tu pourras avoir n'importe laquelle de
seamus 3 passes et lala qui s'est fait
tirer les rideaux seriez parfaits l'un
pour l'autre
toi tu peux pas bouger ton corps et elle
peut pas bouger sa figure
j'ai pourtant été clair pas de fête mon
anniversaire
désolé que tu es droit à une fête
surprise quand on appartient c'est bon
il y en a qui ont des frais problème moi
je me bats pourquoi mon fils à qui la
faute si tu n'a plus droit de le voir
une bonne je veux la paix dès cet
automne bouteille vanity moreau
[Musique]
de la péter les plombs
et celle de détente je suis père détendu
j'ai jamais été aussi détendu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]